samima begum a young woman who left
London at the age of 15 to join isil has
lost the appeal against the removal of
her British citizenship this information
just in let's bring in Nadeem Baba he's
joining us from London so what does this
mean for her Nadeem
well this is clearly a setback for
shimima begum who is still in that camp
in Northern Syria where she was found to
be living
in 2019 four years after she left her
home in East London with two friends to
go to Turkey and on to Syria into the
so-called caliphate uh run by isil
so-called Islamic State but this is not
the end of the uh the legal challenge
that she can bring she can go to the
court of appeals here in the UK the
Supreme Court after that and then her
lawyers have even suggested it could go
to the European Court of human rights
now her citizenship was stripped back in
2019 by the then Home Secretary Sajid
Javit he was criticized by a former
director of public prosecutions at the
time saying that he'd done so just
because he he wanted to further his aims
to become Prime Minister out of ambition
and that individual said it was immoral
there was no significant part of British
public opinion very hostile to shimima
begum back then who'd gone uh obviously
of her own volition to Syria she since
has given interviews in which she says
that she would be prepared to stand
trial for a membership of isil a
terrorist organization she denies ever
carrying out violent Acts or preparing
them or training people to do so some
public sympathy has actually swung her
way in those interviews in recent months
and years where she said house she had
to marry an eyesore fighter she lost
three young children when she was out in
Syria
and she basically has challenged um her
um her British citizenship removal
saying that it rendered her stateless
which it affect delivery has done the
British government says she could apply
for Bangladeshi citizenship that country
wants nothing to do with her but her
lawyers have also argued that the
government have failed to take into
account the fact that she was
effectively the victim of trafficking
right so remind us once again how the
government actually fought to keep her
from returning to the UK native
well all along they have presented this
as a matter of National Security
originally the court of appeals said
that she remember begum could come back
to Britain to try to get her citizenship
back in 2021 the Supreme Court
overturned that ruling
um and the the grounds for that was
National Security saying that hadn't
been given sufficient consideration just
at the end of last year when this
hearing started the government lawyers
again were stressing that behind their
reasoning was that if she were allowed
to come back it would expose the public
to an increased risk of of terrorism
even if shimima bacon did get her
citizenship back she'd be in the
situation of perhaps dozens of people
still in Syria who'd gone to join isil
who are actually not allowed to come
back the authorities there will only uh
grant them permission if the UK
government says please do so they're not
minded to do that it's a very unusual
situation compared to many other
countries including around Europe and
the US who have repatriated their
citizens uh often to stand trial or to
be held in high security facilities but
for now shamima begum is stuck in Syria
thank you so much Nadine Baba for that
update from London